SRINI DEVADAS: We're going to
do something quite different
in terms of a puzzle.
And while it's a
recursive puzzle,
it's going to play out to
be a recursive solution.
It looks quite different
from the N-queens puzzle.
And so this is going
to be a tiling puzzle.
And so I set up the
puzzle, and then we're
going to take a little segue
off into a canonical recursive
algorithm called merge
sort because I think
it's good for you to see that
algorithm before you dive
into solving this
particular puzzle
because it kind of
shows you the way.
All right, and but
I'll set up the puzzle.
I guess I didn't have
to erase this square.
It's a courtyard
that has a bunch--
of tiles.
You're supposed to tile it,
and it's all square tiles.
And I'll just make it eight
by eight like a chessboard.
And in general, we
are going to say
that this is a 2 raised to n
by 2 raised to n courtyard.
And I want to tile
this courtyard.
So this is a three tile--
some people call it a tromino.
You can think of it's
really an L-shaped tile,
and it can be oriented
in any different way.
It could be an
inverted L, et cetera.
And you're supposed to tile this
courtyard using L-shaped tiles
or trominos.
And they're called
trominos because there's
three tiles in there--
three squares in there.
And so that's your job.
I guess kind of a weird
job, but this is a puzzle.
And so you're out there with 2
raised to n by 2 raised to n.
And all you have are
these L-shaped tiles,
and you're not
allowed to break them.
If you break them, then that's
not considered a valid tiling.
That's bad, and that's your job.
Oh, and obviously, it
needs to look like this,
and these look like the floor.
Maybe you'd like to see
the markings because these
are tiles, after all.
But you can't have
something that is uneven.
You can't have a tile
on top of another tile.
That's a definite no-no.
And you can't not have a tile
in any part of the courtyard.
So I think that was
kind of obvious,
but it's worth
explicitly stating just
so you don't get confused here.
So that's the question that
we're going to try and answer.
But as I said, I want to talk
about something a little bit
different for about
5 or 10 minutes
and actually show you
some code because I
want to introduce
this notion that's
a little bit different from the
N-queens recursive paradigm.
It is recursive, but it's called
recursive divide and conquer.
And usually, when we use
the term recursive divide
and conquer, you might think
that it's applicable, even
to the N-queens recursive code.
But from a technical
term standpoint
when we say recursive
divide and conquer,
we're really saying that
we're taking the problem,
and we are dividing it
up into smaller problems.
So you take the problem,
and you divide it
into two problems that are half
the size or three problems that
are a third of the
size et cetera.
Which is not what happened
in the case of the N-queens
problem.
And in the case of the N-queens
problem, you took a column,
and you actually did
iterations on the column.
So it potentially
exploded on you.
And then you had a problem
that is slightly smaller
than the N-queens.
It was effectively
n minus 1 queens.
And so it's not n over 2
or n over 2 or 3-- n over 3
in the case of a three-way
recursive divide and conquer.
So there's a
qualitative difference.
And there's also a quantitative
difference in the sense
that these kinds
of algorithms are
going to be efficient
in that they are going
to run very quickly
in polynomial time,
perhaps quadratic time.
We can do some analysis for both
of the merge sort that we're
going to do now
and for the tiling
puzzle, once we get to that.
But that's something
to keep in mind.
So merge sort is the
canonical recursive divide
and conquer approach.
And I'll put up code
for it, but I'm not
going to show it to you.
You can look at
it in the website.
But I'm going to
describe the algorithm
to you using a trivial example.
And so I want to sort these
numbers in ascending order.
So I have these four
numbers that I want
to sort in ascending order.
And obviously, I could do
this many different ways.
We looked at selection sort.
But this is a large
array, and I want
to do something more efficient
than that quadratic algorithm
and n squared algorithm.
And merge sort, which is
recursive divide and conquer,
fits the bill.
And what merge sort says is
I'm going to split the array.
I'm just going to
take this array,
and I'm going to split it
up into two sub-arrays.
And I could do this
recursively, but let's just
talk about the first step.
So I'm going to go ahead
and split this array up,
and I have 76 and 32.
And I'm going to call merge
sort on this smaller array.
And the first thing
that merge sort does
is split the array up
into something smaller,
and you end up getting that.
So this is the first thing,
and that's the first split.
And then you end up
splitting 48 and 32,
and I'm sorry-- or
12, 76, 32, 48, 12.
Yep, I got that right.
And so far, you've done nothing.
I mean, you've just
sort of broken things up
and turned this into four
one arrays or one list
or what have you.
But then the fun
starts where after you
do the split, after you
return, and so 76 as singleton
is trivially sorted so
there's no work to do.
So there's no more
splits that you could do.
There's nothing
that says you can--
I mean, 76 is a monolithic
element in their array,
so you can't do
anything with it.
And so you just leave it be.
And the same thing with
32, and so on and so forth.
But after your two
calls return, you
have to merge the two together.
And the way you merge
the two together--
the invariant here is that when
you merge the two together,
they have to be
sorted in the order
that you want the overall
array to be sorted,
which is ascending order.
So in this case, you
have down at the bottom,
it's trivial code because
you have two singleton lists.
And you just decide
which order they go into.
OK, so the merge, in this
case, would simply be produced,
you would produce 32 and 76.
OK, and in this case, the
merger produced 12 and 48.
So at this level, you're going
to return 32 and 76 back.
You're going to
return 32 and 76 back.
And here you're going to
return 12 and 48 back.
Now it gets a little
more interesting.
Now it gets a little more
interesting because now you
have 32 and 76 and 12 and
48, and those are both
sorted in ascending
order, and you
need to merge them together.
And so if you had
a 128 element list,
you would go, go,
go all the way down,
and then you would
do some merging.
Come up all the way and then the
most time-consuming step really
would be taking two
64 element lists
that the left one is
in ascending order,
and the right one is
in descending order.
And then you need to
merge them together
so the result is
in ascending order.
That makes sense?
And so in this
case, the way we're
going to do this
is if you have--
and I can do this for this
example or a different example.
But I'll just stick with 32,
76, and this could be larger.
This is 12 and 48.
So I need to merge these two
to produce in ascending order.
And we use a
straightforward algorithm
that's called the
two-finger algorithm, which
says I'm going to start
with my fingers pointing
to the beginning
of the two arrays,
and I'm going to choose
the element that's smaller.
And I'm going to write
it into my output array.
So I'm going to
compare 32 and 12.
12 is smaller, so I'm
going to write 12 down.
And because I picked
12 from this array,
and I didn't pick 32, I'm going
to leave my top finger where
it is, and I'm going to
move my bottom finger--
my right-hand finger--
over to the next element.
And then I'm going to compare
32 with 48 because this finger
didn't move.
And I'm going to figure
out which one is smaller,
and it's 32.
And I'm going to
put that over here.
And then I'm going to move this
finger because I took away 32.
And then at this 48 is smaller,
and then I'm off this way,
assuming the array ended here.
But if it didn't, I keep going.
And then the last thing
I do is put 76 down.
So that is a recursive
divide and conquer algorithm.
It's the simplest
algorithm I can think of,
and that is still interesting.
I'll show you code for it.
I'm not going to explain it.
It is worth looking
at the overall code.
And then the merge, which is
this two-finger algorithm,
is actually the
most amount of code.
But the split itself,
as you can see, is you
see as with our
recursion, we say
we want to have a base case.
And so when the length
of the list becomes 2,
I'm just going to
do that little flip.
This is a sorting
algorithm that only
works for a list of length 2.
But the beauty of this is
that I can keep going down
to get smaller
and smaller lists,
such that the sorting
algorithm actually works.
And this is it.
This is a fine sorting
algorithm for a base case.
And we do have a base case here.
We also have the other property
that I'm actually calling.
I'm making two recursive calls
with significantly smaller
problems.
In this case, I'm
using list splicing
to get the first
part of the list
and the second part of the
list, and I'm just calling
merge sort on those two lists.
And then finally, the
workhorse in merge sort
is the merge step--
this two finger thing
that I just described to you.
That is this merge thing.
And this merge thing,
as you can see--
there's not a lot of code.
But it's doing this movement
and the comparisons.
And that's essentially
what you have there.
So given that context--
right given that context, let's
go back to our tiling puzzle.
And let's talk about this
tiling puzzle and how we could
we could solve
this tiling puzzle.
So you're going to break
this courtyard up clearly
because that's
really what I've been
trying to tell you in terms of
recursive divide and conquer.
First question-- look
at this 2 raised to n,
and 2 raised to n, and
look at this three tile.
I am going to ask
you the question.
Is there a solution
that is a perfect tiling
with no overlapping tiles and
no squares with holes in them?
Is someone?
Fadi had his hand up first.
Go for it.
AUDIENCE: Well, if we look at
the case of n is equal to 1,
you have a two by two
courtyard, then it's impossible,
you can see that trivially.
But in a general case, then we
will have 2 to the 2n squares.
And every time we're adding
3, 3, 3, the number of tiles
is a multiple of 3.
SRINI DEVADAS: Correct.
So 2 to the 2n-- and Josh
probably had the same answer--
2 to the 2n is not
a multiple of 3.
The only thing that
divides it is 2.
So OK so we're going
to change the problem.
We're going to say
that there's a statue
of your favorite person that
is going to be out here.
And so you don't
need to tile that.
So now you have 2
raised to 2n minus 1
let me write that out properly.
2 raised to 2n minus 1 squares.
Now can you do this for all n?
Clearly, it works
for n equals 1.
And then for n equals
2, you have what?
2 raised to 4, which
is 16 minus 115.
That seems to work.
And then you get
up to, I think 80--
what is it?
2 raised to 6 would be 64.
And so that will be 63.
That works too.
In general, does it work?
It does.
So it turns out if
you think about it,
you can write this out
as 2 raised to n minus 1
times 2 raised to n plus 1.
And in the middle there, pretend
that there's 2 raised to n.
So you have three
consecutive numbers.
And when you multiply
three consecutive numbers,
they're consecutive.
Doesn't matter what
the numbers are.
The product is always
going to be a multiple of 3
because one of those things is
going to be a multiple of 3.
And you know that 2 raised
to n is not a multiple of 3.
This is not a product of
three consecutive numbers.
But if it were, and you
pretended that 2 raised to n
was in here, either this
one is a multiple of 3,
or that one is a multiple of 3.
So this is good.
So we know that at least
from a standpoint of volume--
our surface area, if you will--
that this is going to work.
Whereas the original problem
didn't work from a surface area
standpoint.
So it comes down
to how am I going
to solve this problem using
recursive divide and conquer?
And so I can break this up.
And you want to have a similar
feel to the merge sort,
where when you go down to
the base case of merge sort,
you had this trivial
problem to solve.
That's the beauty of
divide and conquer.
It becomes obvious when you
have such a small problem
like one queen.
That's not technically
not divide and conquer,
but you do get to
the smaller part.
But clearly, in this case,
this is a classic divide
and conquer
algorithm merge sort.
And you can see that the first
two or three lines of code
are the trivial case
of two elements that
needed to be sorted.
So let's go back
and forget that.
Let's look at this
picture and think
about how you'd break this up.
How would I bring this up?
So think two-dimensionally.
And merge sort was
a single dimension.
OK, think two dimensional.
This is two dimensional.
This is a
two-dimensional problem.
It's in that sense,
closer to N-queens.
But merge sort was simply
a single dimension.
All right, I see Kevin had--
Fadi had his hand up.
Kevin has a hand up.
Someone else?
All right, go ahead, Kevin.
AUDIENCE: Do you keep cutting
the square into quarters?
SRINI DEVADAS: Quarters-- good.
OK, yeah.
So all right, so let's do that.
Let's do that.
You're on the right track.
And by the way, this particular
thing could be over there.
And I'll just do this
just to make sure.
Your algorithm needs
to work, regardless
of where that statue is.
So maybe the statue
is over here.
Maybe the statue is over there.
There's only one statue
that is covering one square,
but it's not necessarily
in near the center.
It could even be anywhere.
You need a
general-purpose scheme
that would work, regardless
of where the statue is as long
as it only occupies one square.
That's the only
constraint we have.
So you're on the
right track, Kevin.
Someone else or, Fadi,
you want to add to that?
AUDIENCE: So in something
that's similar to the merge sort
so you divide it into
quarters and then you
reach the base case and
then we tile that obviously
with an L shaped tile.
SRINI DEVADAS: Right,
that's exactly right.
So yeah.
So that there's one thing
that's missing in what
both you and Kevin have put up.
The thing with merge sort was
I had exactly the same problem
to solve.
It was exactly the same problem.
It was just smaller.
I needed to sort the smaller
array in ascending order.
And I had two of them, and it
was exactly the same problem.
But when I split this up
into four quarters like you
guys are suggesting, do I
have exactly the same four
problems to solve?
In fact, can I even
solve this the 16 problem
with L-shaped tiles?
I can't.
So at some level, I have three
problems that I can't solve.
And then a smaller
problem that I don't quite
know how to solve-- other
than maybe splitting it up
even more, which is kind of
interesting, which is good.
But then the next
time, if I go ahead
and split that, then wonderful.
I will find one problem that's
two by two that I can solve,
but that doesn't
solve my puzzle.
So I have to do one
more thing in order
to make this look like merge
sort or any recursive divide
and conquer.
One of the paradigms of
recursive divide and conquer
is you're not creating
new types of problems.
You're creating the same type
of problem, except smaller.
And therefore,
eventually easier.
So I have to do one more thing.
And this is an aha moment
here that I'm hoping--
I don't want to
take an answer yet
because I want you
to think about it
and perhaps arrive at it.
But it's one of those things
where you're going to go "oh!"
if you don't know the answer.
But it is worth spending
another minute--
another minute for each
of you thinking about it.
How am I going to set it up so
these quarters-- so all of this
is good?
I'm going to split
it up into quarters,
but I want all four problems
to look exactly the same
in the sense that they look--
this obviously looks different
from these other ones.
Well, there's a
tile missing here,
but there is no tile missing
over in the other three.
So how do I make all
problems look the same?
I know you know,
but we need more.
I'll give you 30 more
seconds, and I'll
give you one more hint.
All! right, the hint
is place one tile--
place one L-shaped tile.
All right.
Yeah, go for it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you know that
with those last four quarters--
you know that that
L-shape has to go around?
SRINI DEVADAS: Yes.
Yeah, that's right.
So you set it up so you tile.
The reason I picked
this L-shape this way
is because this was the statue.
So I wanted to remove a tile
from each of the other 3/4.
I'm sorry, remove a square.
A tile is L-shaped.
And so this was
a missing square,
which was part of the
specification of the problem.
It has nothing to
do with the tile.
It's just a missing square
because there's a statue on it.
But what I could do is if I
oriented the tile in this way,
now I have this being a
smaller problem, which
is one-quarter of the size of
the original problem with one
square missing.
This one is one square missing.
Now that makes all of the
problems look the same.
Now, at first, they're not
exactly the same in the sense
that the missing square is
in a different position.
But there's some generality that
we need in our algorithm that
says that eventually, if
I keep breaking this up
in this fashion, I just need
to orient my L-shaped tile
in the appropriate way.
So there's only
four different ways
that an L-shaped tile
is going to be oriented.
It could be oriented like this.
And I won't draw all of them.
It could be oriented like that.
And it could also
be that's the same.
So what else is there?
Oh, it could be
flipped this way.
Yeah, like that
and the fourth one.
So that's what I did here.
This one is what I put up there.
And then as I break
this up, let's
just say that now I'm going
to make four recursive calls.
I'm going to place one tile--
one L-shaped tile--
and I'm going
to mark off of these things.
And I'm going to make
four recursive calls
to basically myself, except that
the arguments are different.
It's the same code, obviously.
So when I go up
here, I go like that,
and hopefully, this
will become clearer
if you're going to
do a tiling here.
I'm going to go focus on the top
left, and I'm going to do this.
What am I going
to do with respect
to this at this particular
quarter of the courtyard?
How am I going to orient the
L-shaped tile for this one?
Point with your fingers.
Exactly right.
So this is the same as this.
I'm going to go
ahead and do that.
So now I have this problem.
So I'm going to mark that
with a different color.
So I'm focused on this problem,
and I've done that break.
And now I'm good because I have
four two by two courtyards,
and each of these
four has one square
missing in each of these four
little two by two courtyards.
So clearly, I can solve that.
And then once I solve that,
I move on to this one,
and I move onto this one--
whatever order you want.
That's it.
And so the code for this is--
from a control flow
standpoint, from a standpoint
of the overall algorithm, it's
extremely straightforward.
It's almost exactly
like merge sort,
except that you have
four-way recursion
because it's two
dimensional, and you end up
getting quarters.
And the only thing that's
annoying about this code
to write and also to understand,
which you guys will--
I'll put this up, and I'll
show you what to look for--
is how you represent
this as such
that you get all
the values right.
So you get an arbitrary square,
to begin with, that is missing.
And then you have
to go to the middle.
That's clear.
You're going to go to the
middle of this courtyard,
and you're going to split it.
And you're going to decide
which way this L-shaped tile is
oriented, and then you got
to do the splitting again
and so it's just bookkeeping.
That's really what
this is all about.
It's not algorithmically
interesting.
It's just bookkeeping in
terms of the orientation
of these L-shaped tiles.
So if you look at
the code, and if you
ignore a bunch of these indices
of these different variables--
let me show you.
Well, first, I'll show you what
happens when you run the code.
I'm running it for two
different kinds of courtyards.
And I've used A through,
I guess, something like S,
in this case, to signify a tile.
So you see AAA here.
AAA is an L-shaped tile.
BBB is an L-shaped tile.
FFF is an L-shaped
tile, et cetera.
The original specification
of the problem--
this is just simply an
eight by eight problem--
had this tile that you see here.
That's a blank that I've
covered up that was missing.
I'm sorry, this square missing.
And then I broke this up
into two or four 4 by 4's.
And then I went all the way
up and then the first tile
that I placed, I pretended to
place this U tile over here.
I could've placed it and
then called it the A tile.
But this is essentially what you
think of the one in the center
exactly the way
this is oriented.
That's your U tile over here.
And then you go
all the way down.
And explicitly, it's just the
A tile that displays first,
and then the B tile,
and so on and so forth.
And if you take a look
at the code, what's
the best place to start?
So this is the base case--
same thing as we've
talked about before.
You always need to
have a base case.
The base cases is a two by two.
And this code places one
L-shaped tile on a two
by two yard.
This is going to make four
recursive calls, as you
can see from range
four, and there's
two different kinds of
recursive calls in the sense
that they're both
calling recursive tile,
but the arguments of
the recursive style
are different for
this recursive call
because it already had
the missing square in it.
And these three
recursive calls that are
going to have the missing
square in one of their corners.
So that's why you see
the if and the else here.
And if the original
for the recursive
call that already had
the missing square
because it had the statue on
it, that's the if statement.
And the other ones are the
ones that are in the corners.
So the first things it would
be a corner for this one.
This is the corner of
that, one and that's
the corner of that one.
So that's pretty much all I had.
This code-- you need to
gaze at it for a few minutes
to figure out that I got
all the arguments correct.
But from a standpoint
of, as I said,
the control flow
and the algorithm,
it is hopefully completely
clear to you at this point.
If not, ask me questions.
Come to office hours.
Have a good long weekend.